يا روحي يا ماما يا روحي يا ماما يا روحي
يا
ماما يا روحي يا ماما روحوا في عيد
ميلادهم مني يا ناس في عيد ميلادهم راحوا
[موسيقى]
منش قصفوا البيت اللي احنا فيه الطبق
الثاني زل الردم على الطابق الارضي احنا
كنا بالطابق
الارضي الاولاد كانوا نايمين عند عمتهم سش
عمتهم معاهم عمتهم
الكبيره استجد في تاريخ 28/12 يومه عيد
ميلاد كانوا اودي كانت بنتي بتقول لي يا
ماما بدي كيكه يا ماما بدي كيكه يا ماما
عملين لي عيد ميلاد بقول لها بعد العرب يا
ماما بعد العرب يا ماما اخذوا مني اولاد
الله يحصر قلوبهم حصروا قلبي عليهم ه
الاولاد يا رب بعد خمس سنين شفتهم والله
بعد خمس سنين ربيتهم من حبات عيني
الاولاد بعد خمس سنين شفتهم والله شحته من
الله شحتها قلت له يا رب عوضني يا ربنا
حعك يا رب لا اعتراض على حكمك يا الله لا
اعتراض على حكمك يا الله اللهم اجني في
مصيبتي واخلفني خيرا منها يا الله الله
يرحمهم الله يرحمهم يا رب يا رب احنا
نازحين احنا من منطقه الشيخ رضوان احنا
نازحين من منطقه الشيخ رضوان على منطقه
الصراط
نزحنا في تاريخ
1310 تاريخ 1310 نزحنا الله لا يسامح كل
واحد كان بيقدر بيقدر يساعدنا وما ساعدنا
الله لا يسامح كل واحد بيقدر يفكنا من
هالحرب وما فكنا يا رب يار يار يا رب ارحم
ضعف قلبي يا الله يا رب